[Music]
dance
cause you'll be down to bring the family
alone by the spot on the lawn and play
this song
[Music]
dance
shake
[Music]
glorious
on your face
[Music]
[Applause]
like a six am parade
[Music]
sunrise
i'm sorry
[Music]
yeah
baby welcome to the world famous
stuttering john podcast from your
favorite world famous host stuttering
john melendez i don't know i gotta get
some more shirts
freaking stained shirt
anyway there's the link if you want to
donate paypal dot me slash john melendez
inc paypal dot me slash john melendez
inc
and um
obviously you're just donating to me
right now although it was very
um interesting i did have a phone
conversation with the with the person
whose
spouse is going through chemo we had a
long discussion
last night
and this person one of our chatters
might
actually allow me
to say his or her name
uh
because the good news
is is that the
this person's spouses
is um
taken to the chemo so they got another
12 more sessions now
which is a lot more money so
i don't know
i'll let you know but if this person
allows me to say his or her name i will
and then that day
i would set up another day of just
everything that would go to this person
contrary to some
loser anyway patty freeburn joni
heisenberg judge cannon ruled the stigma
associated with the subject seizure in a
league
is in a league of its own trump made the
investigation public does that sound
like someone's concerned with his
reputation
uh john check out the good liars suite
showing them handing out top secret diet
documents at the rally already saw it
jamie raskin said he expects the john 6
committee
final report to come out by the end of
the year after the midterms why after
why after
damn it
marco v 193
where were the
can you believe adult 45 claimed
had dinner he had dinner with mark
zuckerberg last week at the white house
did but i didn't leave a key under the
map i know i saw that
i i didn't really quite get it
does he think he's still in the white
house
you know i mean
i mean you know he might have some form
of dementia
tony heisenberg politico's new owner
of matthias
invited colleagues to pray for trump's
re-election bid in 2020. i know this is
getting scarier
it just keeps getting scarier each day i
don't i don't know what that is but
i don't get it at all
uh
[Music]
joni heisenberg you've got a friend than
me if will readings
cnn ever want conservative they would be
an absolute gold mine to help them do so
trump of course
nanaki
uh
johnny where in the world does the
former guy get all the rich trolls to
pay for this and that i don't get it
they must be russian assaulty yeah
judge cannon's ruling stops the doj from
further examining seized materials until
the special master completes their
review just delayed is justice denied
yep it's infuriating
elizabeth stage dog
anastasia
the cynthia rice
bob carmody
joni doj must also withdraw any witness
subpoenas
issued
issued based on the documentaries that
mar-a-lago
unbelievable bob carmady my mom's here
andrea brower my moderator
shorty one
uh
cat
uh facebook people join this broadcast
you can support my page by sending stars
a digital gift that helps me earn money
uh
justin pennington
mark hurley from ireland tammy pearson
captain turp william zavala
christa barker aileen connie heather
andrea mccready
jules david sancy chemtrup
johnny morris
yvonne watkin
carl todd lola bell 59
uh
yeah yeah yeah midas bob garvey
i'm now addicted to all of these pro
democracy channels that i'm feeling good
i don't know about
one love yep one love
forest ritchie
uh
[Music]
let's see
the squeegee's in the house
is here diana olson from dallas texas
i'm texas
texas we had some fun
russell johnson barely made it well that
radio is really holding up
midas mighty in the chat yep i have tony
michaels and gabe lopez on from the
minus mighty today
uh
i i don't know if this is real but
thanks for the 10 bucks sound horizons
could you shout out to my friend nicker
oh i okay
you got me he's a huge big fan of yours
since the stern days
nicholas gur
yeah
uh
let's see
peter
uh
peter i know all about it just
you know
don't worry about it in due time let's
see if this is
this might be real philo the clown
uh
oh no i guess they're at full force
today thanks for the 20 bucks though
uh when i would reign
raid the bars of america for the whipped
cream cans with money in hand yep i used
to love doing them whippets
uh
yes i know i know lucky seven thanks for
the two bucks
uh it takes a real real real man to uh
uh you know to goof on someone's
children
okay here is uh my guest today
cliff hector
the ultimately very busy cliff schechter
how are you
i'm doing okay you know you're we're all
busy right you're a busy man
there's uh
there's there's there's bad people out
there trying to do bad things in our
country and uh
i see you've got some idiots for asking
you on there too i have those people too
oh yeah yeah i mean it's
it you know
to me i it doesn't bother me
but when they go after
someone's children it's
it's you know it's it's kind of like
cowardly and low you know what i mean no
i mean i agree with you i mean i i
most of time with a i think we had this
chat offline when the ones who came
after me i mean look i you know i i i
was introduced to this world i started
going on msnbc and cnn and fox even
doing debates around 2006-78
and i wrote a book on john mccain that
was very critical of him it's funny
because they said much meaner things
about john mccain in later years trump
himself than i ever did but i was
critical about him in in a critical of
him in a number of ways and
you know i started getting the usual
stuff then but the death threats and the
and all the other kind of stuff you know
the nasty stuff and that was like even
that was pre twitter i mean if twitter
existed in 2008 it was in its infancy
so it was more it was like i get then it
was much more on facebook where that
kind of stuff would happen and whatever
but
you know like you go through a couple
phases i tell people at least for me
which was the first was sort of i was
sort of shocked you know and and it had
its effect i was like oh my god you know
and i took it personally and then then i
got to a point of like nonchalant so i
just didn't even care anymore and it was
sort of like whatever and then i got to
an active point where like i kind of
find them funny
and i challenge them to do better and so
the only thing that bothers me as you
said is when they bring innocent people
into it who shouldn't be there when it
comes to me
like
you know you built my tough skin over
you know six eight years they're
starting in 2008 there's really nothing
after about 2015 that you know
it's just a uh okay
but you see that stupid ugly dumb
ridiculous this that the other thing you
don't like my hair yeah i mean
i don't know what you think you're going
to say that's going to bother me but
but that's the thing like
when they
know that they're not going to bother
because i've been goofed on by the best
i mean
you know i mean howard stern i mean yeah
i mean you know i don't really know
if there's anyone better
at that and then and then
it's so this garbage is not gonna bother
me but
you know so they have to go lower and
try and be on my kids you know which is
right
hey look i even during the credits of
one of his shows
in the old hannity versus combs days i
got i i pissed hannity off so much he
called me [__] the credits were
rolling and banned me from his show
so uh i'm still proud of that i'm not
i'm not going to give hannity credit for
quite being howard stern but uh that
wasn't a you know that was that that i
liked i got rush limbaugh wants to
insult me on his show because i made fun
of him on cnn and somebody sent him the
clip
and uh
you know so you're right like it's like
once that's happened once millions of
people have heard somebody do something
you know go after you like that
i'm not sure what you know joe ed head
in twitter who's got 12 followers thinks
they're gonna
gonna accomplish by insulting me but i
invite them to waste their time
continually doing it if that's what they
want to do
and you gotta tell me what you need me
to do with that uh oh i sent you i'll
i'll send you a follow-up it's just i'm
not you know i'm not technically savvy
it's not that i wouldn't do it no i know
it's all good dude i'll explain to you
offline i'm not the most technically
savvy either i figured it out somehow
so uh cliff let's jump right into it
joe biden is doing an incredible job yup
and i guess the first story we could
tackle
is that he
says
which
rightfully so
that
there is a portion
of this
magga well there's a portion of this
republican party the maga extremists
which are semi-fascists i wouldn't have
used the word semi i would have just
said fascists but it was a big
improvement on
in the past where you know and you know
i've said this on your show multiple
times where i've said or when you'd
asked me what my critiques were somebody
who's a communicating background in
messaging communications it would drive
me nuts it's like you have these big
opportunities to put them on their
defense freak them out make them defend
themselves make them defend all the
crazy stuff they do and you don't do it
and and obviously
i think some of the younger let's call
them sort of the younger uh i don't like
using the word guns but you know the the
younger studs how about that in students
in the democratic party katie porter and
stacey abrams and you know
beto o'rourke with the [__]
heard around the world that he you know
when he said that to that person and and
eric swalwell and i think they have
started changing the culture of the
party we're in making the the some of
the the older folks in the party realize
that you can't we're not dealing with
like a center-right republican party
that has any reasonable people in it
we're dealing with you know again yeah i
mean let me change that i would have
gone further than buying are there a few
decent people left in the republican
party sure i don't know what the hell
they're doing there they've that have
stayed with it most of them are now
retiring i think seven or eight of the
ten who voted for trump's impeachment in
the house will be gone after this cycle
you know um
so is there some decency left but but
what's taken over is the vicious cruel
you know
fascistic uh hatred of others
belief that in the belief that elections
where they don't win are not valid
elections
um you know and that kind of i mean
that's what's taken over and that's
right and that's the message that i love
is biden sort of kicked it off with that
big speech then he went to pennsylvania
marched in labor day parade in
pittsburgh went to some other spots and
he's been he's kept saying it he stayed
on message about it and he's saying i'm
not saying it's their whole party but
it's the driving force it's the ones who
are running things now and the others
are scared of them and that is very very
true whoever isn't a part of them
is still scared enough of them that very
few are willing to speak out and if they
do
what happens is what happens with liz
cheney
yeah no i know and and
it's scary though
to think
that you have these people who went to
law school
at
great colleges
like
like uh
raphael
and rafael ted yeah yeah yeah
and
we'll just
throw all their integrity away
so they could
lick the boot
of this lunatic
fascist
of the authoritarian i never get it
right yeah well here's the thing
i would i would debate you in that he
never i don't think he never had any
integrity i mean did you ever hear you
know his college roommate who when he
was craig was it was his name milan
milken i'm trying to remember the one
that did um
oh the tv show on the nuclear meltdown
in russia
like you know his roommates become a
famous semi-famous producer at least
famous somewhat like some people know he
is and the minute ted started running he
was he would tell stories about what an
evil little nazi he was back when he was
in princeton undergrad the point is is
that
the ones who the most the ones who
joined in loudest with trump are the
ones who are always evil no matter how
smart they were josh hawley went to
harvard desantis went to yale tom cotton
went to harvard which is hilarious when
they attack ivy league schools right
trump went to penn which insults me
because that's where i went um you know
like
when they when they when they sit there
and try to make it like this ivy league
liberals like half all these these guys
you know a lot of them went to these
schools and they're evil they've always
had something wrong with them you know
the types of people that when you hear
those stories from ted cruz you knew
that people always noticed there was
something off
you know that he always was a bit of a
narcissist and a sociopath and so he
always was this was where he was always
going to end up if it wasn't trump it
would be him himself or him following
rand paul or some other nut like that i
don't think he gave up his integrity i
don't think it was ever there but there
are other ones yeah i guess there are
enough i mean look at marco rubio say
yes
just just so everybody knows marco rubio
this week
said that the
documents in mar-a-lago
was just pretty much a storage room
right it was just bad storage yeah
bad storage room which somebody i don't
remember who responded on twitter kind
of like jeffrey dahmer
right bad storage um
yeah he's an ex so he's the example of
exactly
what you were saying before to me which
is he is he at one time when he first
got into this i do think he had some
integrity and he has sold out every last
inch of it because he's scared
witless of doing the right thing and so
he's just going to go with whatever
he is he's a follower he's not a leader
he is completely
a coward
so yeah
jolly rancheros thanks for the two bucks
don't start
don't stop dark brandon round up
magda gqp well that's the thing i mean
joe biden has done more more great
things for this country
in his two years than donald trump
did in his for in fact donald trump
as far as i'm concerned for the most
part cliff did everything bad for this
country and the stench of donald trump
is still stinking up
you know you know this country and
and our elections well donald trump
really because of his tiny brain and
very
over
over enlarged ego
who couldn't admit defeat
he
you know he truly has
turned this country into a it's okay
with people
doing what they're doing as as you know
as you can see in my chat room right now
yeah well he's i mean
there's there's there's no doubt
um you know but i mean he what he's
a
basically
deeply immoral person obviously right i
mean he has no feeling for other people
everything is about him
he clearly is a sociopath i mean i don't
like just throwing the word around but i
mean
what do you say about somebody who sort
of
doesn't care if other people die you
know i mean he admitted you know we have
those private conversations where he
admitted he knew how bad covet was and
went out lied about it to everybody what
do you call somebody that does that that
knows that they're killing people with
what they're saying so
i don't think we've ever had
maybe you know and obviously maybe and
you hear because andrew johnson you know
came in after lincoln who was
apparently a lot like that maybe once or
twice before in history we've had
somebody like that who's been president
but he's in that grouping i mean as much
as i opposed george w bush and a lot of
george w bush's policies sucked
he wasn't selfish in a lot of ways he
was but he actually did have a few
things he believed in
you know what i mean
trump doesn't have anything he believes
he believes in himself he believes in
enriching himself he believes in being
famous he believes in power for himself
like that's it there's nothing beyond
that
no i know and and it really
is
it's scary though because here we have
the midterms
cliff
if we don't if we don't win in the
midterms
donald trump is betting
and hoping
that we lose in the midterms because
then
because then the congress
could start impeachment processes on joe
biden
for whatever they decide to impeach
jamon right they will
if they take the house you could i mean
it's it's
will a couple depending on how much they
take the house by what a couple of them
refuse to do it probably not maybe i
don't know
but if they take a majority
you can bet you're you know the person
who's gonna be running that the house
is not going to be
uh what's his face in california
mccarthy it's gonna be your favorite
marjorie trailer green the only way that
that mccarthy will be allowed to be
speaker will be if he's sort of if he's
just the face
the way when tom delay was the real evil
they allowed denny hastert to be the
speaker for a while of course then it
turned out danny hastert was the real
evil we didn't know what that guy was
doing molesting wrestlers but
but you know because denny hastert put
on this sort of nice old guy face and so
whereas tom delay was his mean sob that
everybody hated
the only way to let kevin mccarthy do it
is if they're calling the shots behind
the scenes which means they'll have to
impeach
by doesn't matter what the reason is
they'll have to hold a vote and the only
question will be how much of a majority
do they have can they hold everybody
on that vote and will every single one
of them be cowards and willing to do it
and i i wouldn't bet on any one of them
having the strength to do anything i
mean i'll admit there were a couple that
surprised me some of the ones in the
house that voted for trump's impeachment
some for the ones in the senate who
voted for
you know for trump to be convicted but
they
there haven't been very many profiles in
courage so you can bet those those
impeachment proceedings will start the
january 6th committee will stop
um
you know like that that's what we're
looking at i mean we have to
we we have to take the house we have to
and we have to or hold it i should say
i'd love to add to our margin but we
have to at the very least even if it's
by one vote
how is it looking though um incredibly
oh you know the problem is 60 you know
nine whatever days in politics is a
lifetime but i mean a hell of a lot
better than was looking a month ago
biden is up seven or eight points in the
polls finally people are feeling the
positives of all the economic
bills and things he did in past mostly
with only democratic support the only
one the republicans supported was the
infrastructure bill and that created a
lot of jobs but the inflation reduction
bill it's money you know money the the
fact that he got a hold of covet and put
money out there with that covered bill
that no republicans voted for when he
first came in got people shots and arms
so people could go back to work and
they're in everything the child tax
credit which helped people what he just
did cutting prescription drug prices in
half i mean i got to tell you somebody
who who worked a lot on washington in
washington and washington stuff for
20 years now more
um that was one of the biggest things we
could never accomplish we tried that so
many times which was to allow
you know medicare to negotiate bulk
negotiate drug prices and it was
criminal that they wouldn't allow the i
mean it was like saying you know john
you can't go buy
the this beer that you want you got to
go buy that i mean it was literally like
to tell people they weren't allowed to
use the democratic process and the
capitalistic process of negotiation it
was ridiculous and finally we got it
done
i mean for seniors what that means in
the end i mean with the power that
medicare has to is that's what all these
european countries do that's what the
veterans administration does they're
going to have the power to negotiate
down the price of a lot of these drugs
by 40 percent
you know i mean so seniors are
going to feel it right we made sure that
the bottom
corporate tax rate is 15 no more amazon
or you know whoever the hell hobby lobby
religious nuts paying like a negative
tax rate they have to pay at least a 15
tax rate and hopefully somewhat more but
at least there's a bot so so many good
things were done right
and and people saw that and then they've
seen the crazy overturning roe versus
wade only eight republicans in the house
or ten what was it eight ten voted to to
say that they would they would fight a
ban on birth control i mean it's ins
that's crazy you know cliff they voted
no on the va bill right and then
pump pumped fists
i mean bump fist i mean
i mean like
it took jon stewart to go in there and
get in and shame them and get public
attention on it so they do it they say
they're all about jobs and they voted
against the chip spill that was all
about rebuilding manufacturing here i
mean but see that
and you know what i
i was watching uh
i was watching the news
uh last night right and
they were playing a clip of the new
prime minister in
england and she was saying
you know
gas prices are high because of the war
in ukraine and and you know
that's why
gas prices that incovid
that's what happened with gas prices
exactly granite lines disrupted yeah
well well yeah and under trump it's
supply and demand everyone's you know
there's a pandemic nobody's driving no
one's buying gas so the price has come
down that's just the normal supply and
demand you take economics 101 in college
they'll tell you that of course
but now the prime minister in england
admits that these gas prices
are high because of the war in ukraine i
had a right wing loon
at one of the watering holes that i hang
out with sit there
and tell me
that like well it's all because you know
biden and i go
i go no it's not it's the pandemic
and it's also with the warren
the warrior
that's why
in ukraine i said well you know that
russia is the third largest oil supplier
in the world right no they're not
yes they are dummy
well also you know they don't want to do
research class well they don't care they
get told what to believe by their own
people but i mean the easiest response
is you're like wow joe biden must be all
powerful because the prices are really
high in france and the united kingdom
and sweden and italy how is it that it's
all joe biden's fault why is it so the
prices for gas so high in all these
other places
now the truth is as you know is that is
that they're still a little bit high but
they've been coming way down they've
been on a downward trajectory because
they've been doing what they can to get
supply lines up and running in a better
way again and and and taking certain
taking various other measures to bring
in supplies from other countries and so
it's getting better again you know and
there were some of these guys that were
gouging you know and they shamed them uh
apparently into gouging a little bit
less so i mean even that's gotten better
inflation is i hear that it's it's
finally under three dollars in uh uh you
know like you know uh the country's
average so it's like
this is see cliff this is the stuff that
i'm hoping
that we run into
in the midterms like if gas prices are
down yeah
at the same time that
they're banning abortions
and suppressing the votes against people
of color
it could be the perfect storm for us
well you've seen it
i mean how does sarah palin lose in
alaska i know i mean obviously she she's
very unlikable but but her people like
her you know i mean that's a red state
she should have won that that seat new
york 19
a lean red sea they should have won we
won in kansas kansas for [__] sake i
mean
you know like they the
the place voted for trump by 15 points
and their their uh their bill to abandon
abortion lost by 18.
that is a 33 point swing
i mean i'm just saying like
you know
they're losing big in these places
there's an article in one of the
newspapers one of the i think the
washington post
all about how republicans thought this
was going to be a big election for them
and they can't believe how much they're
getting destroyed among women
like destroyed
so yeah i mean look nothing is
guaranteed and i don't want anybody to
get overconfident everybody needs to you
know if you've got the money to do it
donate to your candidates that you like
and who can win you know if you can go
knock on doors do it make phone calls
for them do it do whatever the hell you
can do do this if you can you know if
you've got a youtube i don't care if you
have 500 5 500 000 followers get out
there and tell them the kinds of stuff
that we're saying but but right now
all those positive economic trends are
and stuff with bills that biden passed
are why he's now at about 45 46 approval
rating
in inching up towards 50 again and and
it's all the reason why the that people
are horrified donald trump and his
espionage and stealing documents and
starting inciting a coup and the
right-wing crazy supreme court
banning abortion i mean you you see all
this stuff going on together and and
this doesn't look like a normal midterm
right now because normally in midterm
there people will say is a referendum on
the incumbent president and generally it
is but when the other guy never went
away and keeps acting like a jackass and
keeps you know breaking the law and his
supreme court does what they did it's
now it's in a referendum on them
what they're really trying today well
elizabeth thanks for the two bucks
special
master
bader you see what's going on today
you know
and it's hard when you're doing this
you know and talking and having a
conversation to actually you know get
that they're [__] with the you know
with these names you know what i mean
well i have to admit that even i when i
heard this
you know special master thing i'm like i
was thinking of the seinfeld episode
master of your domain yeah no i know i
know are you kid guys kidding me with
this
well
but i you know i'm glad they brought
that up because everyone's talking about
this cannon thing
now
she
has not been appointed yet as a special
master has she
well she's the judge i think she
appoints somebody
so she a trumper is gonna support is
gonna appoint a trumper
oh this is just [__] the whole thing
it's so damaging to the credibility of
our democracy i mean it's just i mean
here's this person she's like 40 she's
never been a judge before
she's she's clueless complete trumper
lives near mar-a-lago trump likes her
and not only did he appoint her he
appointed her after he lost
so you can imagine you know what her her
her loyalty to him i mean there's no i
mean everybody who's looked at this who
are lawyers like this is a joke the
other judge was handling it she had no
jurisdiction she had no reason to be to
jump in uh i mean the the the sort of
this ignores all precedent there's no
executive privilege for him he's not the
executive anymore
you know but so what
see i don't i don't know if like
explain to me and you know i'm sure tony
and gabe because they've been tweeting
about it all day but
i mean explain to me what this i don't
get this whole and explain to my
audience
what is this special master like i don't
you know he was guilty he had the
documents they were top secret they were
classified end of story why does it why
does it have why does he have any rights
after that
because they're all you're right and
again
in a
fully functioning democracy he wouldn't
and he'd be in prison right now i mean
that's uh you know i've said many times
like
you know i'm not i'm not saying
everything merrick garland has done as
bad but has been so close overly
cautious to the point of it's painful
yes if any one of the rest of us
were found with the documents lying
around in a room that we'd stolen
they're classified like that one
somebody shared a story about somebody
who acts who took one document off
illegally off of uh of a base and spent
18 months in prison for it look a
reality winner yeah she's a perfect
example too i mean so that's the first
thing is that i can't explain it to you
legally because there's really no legal
justification for the fact that he's not
in prison at this point that i'm aware
of no there isn't so what does a special
master
do i guess they go through
and especially if i'm sure if they're a
trump person they'll probably try to
make everything look as good as possible
for trump to go through and see if he
took anything that really was you know
dangerous to our national security and
you know and that kind of stuff i think
it's a it's just a delaying tactic for
them
but how about
all the empty
you know all the empty folders right i i
don't that i mean that one i can i mean
how's
whoever it is
the their special master how is that
person going to be able to determine
what where the hell those went i have no
idea
uh
here let me bring in tony he just got
into the room
tony michaels uh from
from the midas touch
uh network this is yeah we're on with
cliff schechter hey cliff how are you
good how are you doing i'm doing great i
just heard you guys talking about the
empty folders and i just wanted to uh
let you know john that gabe sanchez is
not going to be able to join us today
he's been under arrest because he was
caught with some empty folders i'm just
i'm just kidding
i'm just kidding anyone else anyone else
that got caught with with dozens and
dozens of empty top classified ducks
would probably be arrested on the spot
though oh absolutely i guess that's the
point um and i heard you guys talking
about a special master baiter i mean a
special master yeah so i wanted to uh
come on and masturbator and commander i
believe yeah right well i you know i i
don't know exactly
you know the i think uh bill barr just
was on fox news and that's the other
reason why i want to come on because
bill barr
is uh predicting now this is the
nefarious vile uh authoritarian fascist
bill barr the one that donald trump
loved that he buried his russia
collusion with the mueller report that
that same one
yes that one that one the one that i
wouldn't let near our government with
you know then a thousand miles of our
government that's again near children's
playgrounds absolutely but here's the
thing is bill barr is on fox news about
i don't know 15 minutes ago saying that
the doj obviously is going to appeal
this decision for a special master and
they're going to [__] win maybe not
this first appeal but they're gonna win
because this decision to give a special
master is not only stupid it has no
merit based in law i mean there's just
no reason for it and the reason why is
because
it doesn't matter if you get a special
master or not
the fbi or the department of justice
takes very sp special precautions when
there's possible attorney-client
privileged documents inside something
that they seize and the reason why is
because they don't want their case
broken
and if there is just this sliver just
this smidge
of impropriety because they didn't do
their due diligence and make sure that
they separated out documents that had
nothing to do with not only nothing to
do with the criminal case
that weren't uh obvious crimes in and of
themselves
but to separate out attorney-client
privilege documents
then they would be derelict in their
duty and the fbi does that regardless if
someone requests a special master or not
um now normally in normalville which we
do not live in um when you're talking
about lived in for a good seven years
right now well
we live in cheetosville um we don't live
in normalville with trump so in
cheetoville
you would you would assume that he would
understand that the special master has
already been taken care of because the
taint team this is all i'm gonna i'm
gonna bring this up taint team special
master
these things all have these sexual i
don't know why they do this in law but
they do this a lot but anyways um
the the taint team at the fbi has
already done this work and it's actually
if they do get a special master and the
special master does go through this it's
going to be even worse for trump because
the special master has to follow within
the bounds of the law so it's not like
this person just gets to be marshall
dylan and do whatever the hell he wants
um and just run rough shot over the
process he there that person which is
going to be a very slim few amount of
people in this country that number one
have the security clearance understand
what a special mass the laws that uh
bind a special master and understand
what they're looking for it's gonna be a
small group of people that have enough
of a security clearance to go through
this stuff but they're they're with
they're acting within bounds of the law
and
to think that a special master is going
to say oh we're going to take all these
documents and give them all back to
donald trump that's just preposterous
it's ridiculous to even imagine that
that would happen
what they're going to do is say oh the
fbi already did their work they did
their right thing they separated these
documents and
everything's good which is going to be
even worse for trump because there goes
the hole they planted evidence there
goes the fbi and the doj's against me uh
i need to get a special massacre i'm
trying for
cutting you off and and
but
they approved the special master haven't
they
wow i mean the job
has but it there's appeals so the
appeals process to hire courts is what
tony's talking about yeah so i mean
every every every side of a case has the
the right to an appeal a decision so in
other words if this judge would have
decided not to give the special master
um
trump and his team would have the right
to appeal that decision to a higher
court um he didn't have to appeal it
because she granted him what he wanted
which was the special master which is
not what he wants by the way that really
is not what he wants here what he wants
here is to delay that's that's the whole
purpose this has nothing to do with a
special master it has nothing to do with
overt he wants to delay that's his mo he
always does it it's exactly what he
unless he's getting exactly what he
wants then he won't delay like if he's
getting like he wants
tony
and to me and it'll be interesting to
see what happens but the delay tactic is
because he thinks then if he can jump
into the presidential race
then
you know then merrick garland won't be
able to go after him and prosecute him
because then he'd be going after a
candidate and affecting the political
process and blah blah blah i think i
honestly think that's what he's doing
but on the other side of things
the rnc has been paying all his
ridiculous legal bills and ronald
mcdaniel threatened him they only
leverage they have over trump it and
they which was if he got into the race
early they would stop paying his legal
bills
so i don't know when that threat lasts
into whatever but again
as tony said it's all and i was saying
that before to you it's all about delay
you know for him everything is you delay
until the time he dies you know what i
mean like just push it back push it back
you know don't let them get to him
hold on benny loco thanks for the five
bucks
finally a super chatter i could trust
um question can we the people sue him
for damages pain and suffering etc if so
who do we hire
it's a good question i i don't know if
we i i kind of feel like
for that time we had to look at him
stare up at an eclipse
and the other time when he we saw him
climb up the stairs under air force one
with toilet paper coming off of his foot
i think i deserve some kind of damages
for the emotional strain of of seeing
both of those things but i don't know if
i'm i don't know if legally i'm entitled
to it so
why i mean certainly the the people he's
grifted especially with his credit card
scams where he does the uh he does the
uh opt-in feature it's an automatically
opt-in for reoccurring payments um
that's the biggest credit card scam on
the that ever in the history of our
country um there's certainly likely
if they wanted to band together there's
the ability to sue him there but as far
as suing him for
the the the crimes that he's right on
our country that's the department of
justice's job um that's their job and
and they're not let me be clear about
this they're not just
they're not just
probing him
excuse the the um
we're back to special master team today
we were talking about his usual saturday
night right okay but i mean but i mean
here here we are with the legal
difference but they're not just probing
him for the documents at mar-a-lago um
they they there's
this morning we
we there's video out
showing uh sydney powell's i.t person
and a few other representatives of the
trump campaign going into coffee county
which apparently is a very republican
county in georgia and did election
offices which is the same day which is
january 7 2021 i'm gonna bring that up
after the insurrection failed they they
tried this whatever they were trying in
coffee county it seems like they were
trying to make it seem like uh machines
were messed up and tampered with by
tampering with them that's equally
entered whatever the key right they
illegally entered where they yeah this
is the same this is the same problem
that tina peters in colorado has
um but so there's that probe and that's
going to be a federal probe um
eventually the the the other probe in
georgia is the other one about the phone
call with brad rather worker that's a
state probe he also has a federal probe
and a grand jury for january 6 in
washington dc yes he also has a criminal
uh indictment on his own company that he
ran for decades i can't i can't even
remember
why i can't figure out why we can't
remember that the guy who was the former
president who is claiming he wants to
overturn the election
his company that he ran for decades is
under criminal
indictment yeah in new york his cfo has
now pled guilty and is going to turn on
him and then there's a civilian
that's the one where he took the fifth
like 500 times that's the civil the
civil case is the one he took to fifth
and his whole family has taken the fifth
um he's not going to be able to take the
fifth in the criminal case for his
company now rather they'll actually
charge him personally we'll see what
alan weinsteinberg does to flip but the
point is is that his legal problems do
not stop at a bunch of empty folders
down at everywhere right i don't even
know to be honest with you if you think
about wherever he has a property
he is the the i always attach bed bug to
them because i think that's about the
bedbug bedminster the bedbug doral
like
if you think about where some of these
places are i'm actually surprised you
know especially the one in jersey
i mean democratic it's not going to be
republicans protecting him there and i
would think that people said there could
be documents there they still have the
right to go look there yeah yeah you
could end up with both a federal or a
new jersey case against him i mean
dude's broken i mean you know he's gonna
be
being investigated forever right look at
you know teflon don at some point they
put him behind bars al capone at some
point they put him behind bars and
donald trump should not be the exception
well i don't think he's going to be um
and the the commentary says a class
action lawsuit on united states citizen
versus trump the other thing i want to
bring up having to do with that is
there's an insurrectionist he's a county
commissioner i believe in new mexico a
judge ordered this morning that he
cannot hold his office you're an
insurrectionist they use the 14th
amendment to strip him of his elected
office because he's an insurrectionist
um and we're probably going to see more
of this this is just the first domino of
an elected official i haven't seen that
one yet because you've got
koi griffin coy griffin is his name
sorry about it oh yeah i saw him even
trending i didn't have time because you
got mastriano running for governor
correct in pennsylvania he was there
that day uh i mean there's numerous
members of congress who actually
obviously met i don't know if they were
on congressional grounds so i don't know
what the rulings will be about whether
they could be stripped if they were just
at
the ellipse or whatever it is but but
there's at least there's something like
a hundred plus elected officials across
the country um
who who you know because masteriano is a
state senator
um who were and he's running for
governor pennsylvania who were there
that day and crossed illegally the
boundaries um and either it doesn't
matter whether they went inside or not
they illegally crossed the boundaries uh
onto congressional grounds and so
they're insurrectionists right
well and his name again is coy griffin
he's not only a county commissioner
who holds public office well doesn't
anymore in new mexico
but um but also a massive [__] well
yeah
well i mean he is a maga republican but
but he's he is the founder of cowboys
for trump that might ring the bell yeah
he's the founder of cowboys for trump so
and i'm telling you what you're talking
about yes
and he's the one who wears the cowboy
hat but the other thing too significant
about corey griffin is he kind of turned
on donald trump because donald trump
didn't pardon them like he said he would
and that really pissed coy griffin off
that donald trump and and we've noticed
donald trump you know dangling that
carrot again for these morons and some
of them have bought
bit the carrot and some of them have not
but we'll see where that all goes
well that this should be interesting
yeah it's a great point i mean
there's there's a lot of these figures
around the country
and if they end up getting their lives
screwed by the fact that they went and
did this stupid thing
you know they're they're maggot types
right they're the same as donald trump
selfish obnoxious people out for
themselves so half of them may turn on
trump because it's the best thing for
them
you know all right but let me okay so i
just want to
i just want to get this
so you know
can merrick garland say
know what the special master tony and
cliff could he say
well no no no no no no no no he can't
because he's being sued by donald trump
donald trump is suing essentially suing
the department of justice which is
merrick garland
to force them to do a special master
right now if he would have asked for a
special master within the first 24 or 48
hours the department of justice would
have said yeah sure fine
go get a special massacre because they
were doing that process already
that they have the entire courts this so
when you you know he appealed the uh the
the justice department will appeal so
this will go for the although i've heard
that court's very trumpy so that i don't
know if they're going to win there but
then they can still go up to a higher
court that apparently isn't as trumpy
and that's what bill barr is saying on
fox news earlier is that it's likely he
could win the first appeal but he'll
lose the second and billboard
that's right what we're looking at right
and
he's in the lane he's delayed hold on i
gotta understand when does these appeals
get reviewed
our courts are overworked we don't have
nearly enough of them and if you and i
were sitting here talking about
seriously if we were talking about
nothing other than
like boring federal bureaucracy and not
actual politics i would look in the face
and say for example our supreme court
has not grown in size since 1837
and
when we were in a hugely different
country with hugely different issues
with our agrarian country with none of
the that it should be three times as big
today regardless of politics you should
have something like at least 18 if not
27 justices they've refused most cases
that go to them we've done that with
some of the other federal courts we've
added some we still haven't added enough
so the backlog and tony may know more
about this than me but i don't know how
long it'll take because they they all
have these huge i mean they'll try to
speed this case up i'm sure but like
this is a democracy at stake the kid
well yeah but that's not but that's but
you gotta you gotta remember john that
the courts aren't looking at this
through the prism of democracy they're
looking at this as a prism of law and
justice i mean that that's that's the
thing here and
again the department of justice is going
to do they're going to ask for an
emergency appeal so it'll go as fast as
it can so we'll probably have an answer
on the first appeal within two or three
weeks and then the next appeal within
maybe a month or two but that's the
point if you look down the road i mean
he's gonna be not granted a special
master until maybe after the the midterm
which isn't which really again this is
not going to matter this ma special
master talk is all what he wants he
wants to delay he wants us to focus on a
special master so he can so he can
deflect from the empty folders where all
the documents are actually missing and
the crime is right in plain sight i
would say in some ways
it's worse politically for him right
because what ends up happening here john
is
somebody or somebody's
are leaking things we're finding out
stuff right stuff is leaking out about
what trump took and where the folders
were and i mean or none of this would
happen to begin with if you think
between now and november whoever's doing
that isn't going to keep doing that i
mean there's more stuff being leaked
every day that we're finding out so
it's as long as the drip drip drip it's
like a boxer up against the ropes just
like sort of tim you know almost falling
over and they just keep getting punched
in the face right he keeps getting hit
by all this stuff and the thing about it
is as he is further hated
by anybody who's not a maggot nut it
hurts their entire party because they
all that's why there's i did a video at
my you know at the takedown at my
youtube site where i talked all about
the numerous people that have scrubbed
trump from his their their websites now
because the blake masters the one that
you know the the idiot one of the ones
that feel has on strings like jd vance
here in ohio no mention of trump anymore
on his website the one that's running
against um is it abigail spanberger in
virginia a big um race that is a it
could be a hugely important house race
like they could go either way
even though she's awesome the republican
running against her was like the chair
of like hispanics for trump or something
latinos or trump gone off of our website
they're scrubbing him because the worse
things get
the worse being associated with him is
going to get and of course when he
notices this as he started to he's going
to lose his [__] because he can't stand
anybody rejecting him and so you can
have a lot of this infighting in this
crap going on plus mcconnell is fighting
with peter thiel and mcconnell is
fighting with rick scott and mcconnell
was fighting with trump and trump is
fighting with peter field and i mean
like it's just a yeah it's kristin
thanks for the five bucks hopefully this
will set the president to get other
insurrectionists out of office i can
only hope and
roderick berry thanks for the five bucks
trump never
filled or filed while he was potus and
biden is trying to get
do you guys understand this get gold's
humber never filled all these protests
and bias when they get coach
i don't understand
the people am i trying to be a jerk i
just don't understand what yeah no i
know i can't understand it either but
all i know is listen lincoln after
they rejected the election results in
kicked five senators out
southern senators and and they were
kicked out of the senate
there's a precedent for doing it we
haven't done it so far well and that's
that's until today we uh today is the
first time we've used um the 14th
amendment to do that since the 1860s
so
you know i got to go in a minute john it
seems like tony here is a pretty
professional kind of media guy he seems
pretty able so i think he can probably
hold the
hold the interest uh without me here i
have a few yes okay well then cliff
please plug anything that you want to
yeah folks just the the just come to
check out uh the youtube channel which i
just started a few months ago we're
heading towards 10 000 subscriptions
we're growing rapidly so just it's just
uh
youtube.com
c as in my first name cliff schechter
s-c-h-e-c-t-e-r come on by
and um
and you know i'll let tony plug his own
stuff but he's associated with my boys
over there captain jordy in the gang
then he must be doing good stuff so you
so you think jordy is the is the best
brother i mean
um i don't want to pick brothers oh okay
well i mean one i got to meet with you i
used to have a podcast with john
aravosis and yeah and i brett i'm i'm
thinking at the time couldn't make it
and then i couldn't talk to ben right
after so i ended up talking to jordy and
so we just sort of so i don't want to
pick they all seem like awesome dudes
but jordy was the one i got the chance
to talk to i was gonna say because the
minus mighty jordy's the favorite i mean
that that's that's like and he's the one
well that's because he's like quickly
because they all think he's the most
handsome oh is that what it is oh yes
maybe but i i'm saying i'm in the uh i'm
in the midwest and so the fact that i
chose to live in cincinnati and jordy
you know and i'm an east coast i'm
originally from new york like jordan and
i chose to live here for the love of a
good woman and he's doing the same in
pittsburgh
a lot of common is what you're saying
the lining yeah we have a lot in common
there you go okay well next time next
time
like him too right absolutely well next
time i see him i'll tell him that uh
that you said maybe maybe not maybe that
you're the you're he's the favorite now
you say absolutely but you said that to
all three guys right exactly i'll i'll
do that i'll do that all i'm in a
meeting with all three of them all right
i got a 12 year old with a soccer game
coming up so i'm going to go check it
out
thanks so much man thank you roderick
perry thanks for the five buck judges
people and tony let me ask you a
question you know you and i are sports
fans are you a betting man
i can be for this bit go ahead well
betteronline.ag is the fastest and
easiest way to wager on all your
favorite sports
contests and events with first to market
odds and lines fine reviews and news of
every league including major league
baseball nfl nba nhl combat sports
esports and even golf
beenonline.ag continues to be the top
online resource for all your sports
information from live in-game betting
props and futures head to bed online.ag
today or use your mobile device to join
today and make your first sports bet
use our promo code clns50
that
clns50 to receive your 50 welcome bonus
on your first deposit thenonline.ag
where the game starts and now back to
the show with the great tony michaels my
good buddy who yeah who i uh spent a lot
of time talking to on the phone lately
yeah sure sure hey you know um gabe
couldn't make it today he wanted to he
wanted to send his uh his best to you he
again he had a meeting i i was joking
earlier about the empty folders but you
know that is the truth if if anyone else
if you i gave anyone else was caught um
with with just boxes and boxes
of uh empty top secret classified
government folders now we'd be [__]
here's one of the reasons why is because
they don't just hand those out like as
souvenirs um at the government they're
just not like oh yeah take them with me
when you go no problem but also
the documents don't just fall out of
these folders like these are the type of
folders that are secure folders you want
a secure folder is right
it has the big prongs in it that you put
the document in you fold it over so the
document doesn't just
fall out
or fly out
so these documents had to be taken like
physically taken out of these folders
so john what do you think what do you
think could possibly be in these folders
uh i would say our nuclear secrets
our nuclear secrets that's what you
think was in there or gossip on on like
uh
macron and you know
you know like like you know on merkle
like any
anything that could be
detrimental to these people
do you know what i think's in these
these folders are were in these folders
i i think i think what was in these
folders is either hidden somewhere else
or destroyed already
if you rewind back before trump came out
of office when we told him to go get
[__] and 81 million people voted
against him
and he was no gonna no longer be the
president didn't matter what kind of
shenanigans he pulled to try to
overthrow our vote
donald trump was talking about the
russian
classified documents do you remember
this do you remember what he said
what he was going to do he was going to
be transparent and all the documents
that had anything to do with the hillary
clinton emails and the russia collusion
of no collusion no obstruction
do you remember what he said he was
gonna do with these documents do you
remember what he kept saying no please
tell us all tony he kept saying he's
going to declassify all those documents
you remember that
i don't recall but yeah so he said he
was going to declassify all these
documents that had to do with russia and
and that would prove that he didn't
actually collude it was all a democrat
scam and this and that here's the reason
why i think he was saying that
he was saying that then because someone
was telling him at the time
you cannot take these documents with you
these are not your documents
you can't take the documents that belong
to the government that have to do with
you colluding with russia in the last
election you can't do that they're top
secret
and he said well what if i declassify
them and they're like yeah still
probably not but that might be a little
better so that's why he kept saying that
and that's why you see cash patel saying
he stood over these boxes with his big
mac stained hands and he was waving his
hands over these boxes act like he was
magically declassifying these documents
that's why they're saying what they're
saying now this [__] always
tells on himself he can't help it he
always
says exactly what he's doing and why
he's doing it
i actually believe the reason why we
have empty classified document folders
uh that was rounded up in this uh
in this search warrant where they went
and re retrieved their property
and some of their properties missing out
of those folders
is because he took it because it has to
do with him if anyone thinks that trump
took anything i mean anything even a
[__] picture
that wasn't of him
that had to do with him or benefited him
you have not been [__] you have not
been awake for the last [__] six
years
everything that he does every [__]
thing he says every movement he makes
from the time that the guy takes it
wakes up and takes his adderall until he
takes whatever he takes to go to sleep
the guy is only about himself yes full
stop
and those documents and those folders
were about him those documents and those
folders benefited him and him alone
there's no way on earth that he took
these as mementos
no way and there's no way that they're
missing because he wanted them as
momentos think about this john if you
were going to take momentos and then
throw them away or destroy them or give
them away or sell them why would it be a
momento to you
well uh i think you mean a memento
what did i say
momento it's a it's an amendment a
memento yeah that's whatever whatever
the [__] [__] you john
[__] you john i come on your show i try
to drop some knowledge and you make fun
of the way the guy from missouri talks
gabe does the same thing i say
what do you dip your chips in
chips and what salsa
salsa
salsa it's salsa it's with a z it's got
a goddamn z in it i'm from missouri no
it doesn't uh it [__] does
it's salsa
yeah well that may be how you spell it
but that's not how i say it
anyway so what were you saying about the
momentos
what did i say
you said momentos
it's mementos mementos that's what i
said momentos
the [__] out here i should turn this off
you know that no come on i'm just
kidding i'm just kidding i'm just
kidding tell me look i even put this up
for you nancy rose i was watching tony
today and i thought i would love to see
him on john again and here he is see i
even pre-empted that by having that up
there to show you that you got a lot of
fans in this room
well i know i got a lot of fans
everywhere john i'm uh you can collect
these people like momentos
uno memento oh my god [__] you jun
[__] you
[__] you um so what else do you want to
talk about besides empty folders is
there anything
john correcting tony really yeah yeah
[__] this is [__] it's [__]
[__] oh oh this is gonna this is
gonna end up on another website
somewhere i already can tell
this is all out of love you know yeah
yeah well hey i i'm glad i'm glad you
found a way to goof on me
i'm gl i'm glad you finally found the
spot to do that
come on tony i have to you know it's
i mean yeah look it's just because i you
know i'm uh it's all in good fun it's
what people don't know is i give you all
kinds of [__]
yes off yeah off the air here and he
gets all kinds of [__] for me yes but
you know i i am a you know i am a school
teacher tony you know i gotta
i mean i have to point these out so you
don't make the same mistake again
oh is that what it is
yeah i need to go back to school is that
what you're saying no i'm just gonna go
oh i
see tony look at this i got a good
edumacation okay yeah you see
what's this
oh yeah [__] you
[Music]
[Laughter]
get the hell out of here
tony come on i love you bro this guy
this [__] guy i tell you what this
[__] guy
what else do you want to talk about john
we've been talking about trump um do you
want to talk about joe biden in his
speech yesterday or what about i started
the show what's that but it's about to
get your take on that
uh which one the the the one on last
thursday where he dunked uh manga
republicans in the trash or the ones
yesterday where he showed working
americans that he's for them
and then this morning when he said he's
not for wall street he's for working
america
well the thing that really
i thought was so funny tone
was that he
you know calls them semi-fascists
not all republicans
just
the mega
extremists
and man
wow
all the outrage oh well you know i
pulled up an old video that i did like i
don't know two [__] years ago or
something and i did it over on tick tock
because i used to do a lot of videos
over on tic tac and i haven't been
calling them semi-fascist i've been
calling them nazis for a long time yeah
because i i truly believe that's exactly
what they are is nazis now um
when i i played this video because
people would get really mad when i would
call
trumpers nazis they [__] would get so
pissed off they're like oh and it was
always
white people would be pissed off that i
was calling trump supporters nazis i
wonder i wonder why but here's the thing
is that when um
when you call someone a nazi
and they get highly offended and highly
defensive
that's who i'm talking to
like that's who i'm pointing out and
that's exactly what joe biden did
because joe biden
on thursday with his speech
they've been holding that speech for a
while for the correct moment
and they knew that donald trump was
going to speak over the weekend at a
rally in pennsylvania and the one thing
they knew that he was going to do in
pennsylvania is he was going to be on
stage with masteriano who is a [__]
nazi he's a [__] insurrectionist nazi
is what he is
and here's the thing joe biden set the
trap for him on thursday
and boy did trump deliver oh my god that
guy
[__] delivered the mango mussolini
[__] got up on stage and for two
hours puked out nothing but fascism no
policies no real ideas straight on
[__] fascism
and and and talking all about himself
and then
then on monday
yesterday on labor day joe biden isn't
isn't on a golf course somewhere
he isn't [__] he isn't sleepy he
isn't sleepy joe oh put his [__]
shoes on and he went out and he went to
milwaukee which is the home of the union
i don't know if you know that milwaukee
is the home of the union and he went to
milwaukee and he gave a speech about
working americans and working people and
how he is for working people
and it pissed them
off oh they're [__] pissed off that
this guy
gave a speech talking about working
families and working america [__]
pisses them off
and then this morning he sets the trap
for republicans because he set the trap
for student debt they took the bait
he [__] sprung the trap he set the
trap for trump took the [__] bait
sprung the trap
yesterday and today he's setting the
trap for all manga republicans
everywhere he's setting the trap for
them to be against working families and
for wall street he set the trap today
and they're gonna spring it he said he
tweeted this morning he tweeted this
morning republic republicans amanga
republicans in congress just don't get
it
that wall street is not what built
america
working americans working people are
what built america
and if anyone thinks
that you're going to be able to go out
and sell a message against that message
you are a dumb [__]
you are funny
do you
now i i know what my opinion is but i'd
like to get yours do you think biden is
so calculated on this
oh yeah absolutely i mean biden
understands biden understands politics
yes um better than almost anything yes
that that he
that he does i mean if you remember um
the actual national politician
that set in motion
what would be the democratic party
embracing uh marriage equality it was
joe biden that's who did that he went on
uh meet the press
and
just out in the open said you goddamn
right i'm from marriage equality it
makes no sense not to be and and that
that set the that set the footing for
the democratic party to embrace that um
so he understands politics he's been in
it for a long time it's one of the
things that they say
he's the reason why you shouldn't vote
for him is because he understands
politics and like really if he's on our
side i want the guy who understands
i want that [__] i don't want
him not on our side mitch mcconnell
understands politics very well too and i
don't like that he understands politics
he's an evil piece of [__] yes and we
don't want people on the other side that
understand politics that well let me
just
uh roderick barry thanks for five bucks
i believe what tony says
egomaniac hate to look foolish
files he had on him and all stuff he's
been investigated over the years about
that's
in reference to something you said
earlier yeah well i think that has to do
with the russian collusion i think
that's one reason why he took the
documents and he doesn't want to be made
a full of not just not just legally but
uh with history because he i think he
actually thinks if he would he would
destroy these documents or bury him in a
casket somewhere in new jersey in a
ditch with the ashes with his uh his his
ex-wife i'm not saying that's the thing
but i don't know i want to see what's in
that [__] casket um
he buried her in a ditch did you see
that he buried her in a [__] ditch
who uh ivana yeah he buried her in a
[__] ditch that's kind of weird who
would yeah well who who buries your
ex-wife
like on a golf course
i mean like
what
i don't know you know but tony tony
people like
let's say his kids actually wanted to go
and
and see the grave which of course you
know i doubt they will but if they did
they gotta dodge golf balls coming at
them i mean
i mean
i
you know a lot of people say that he did
it because um
some kind of tax break or something i
don't actually i i don't think that's
true because if you go actually look at
the tax law that he has to apply for the
tax thing beforehand i mean there's no
way he would get that tax exemption
before he actually put her in the ground
and the tax exemption actually has to be
active before you you start to bury the
body so even if that was his attempt
he's a [__] idiot and he didn't do it
right
um
but i mean i actually i actually believe
he's he did it to control her grave and
there's a reason why he wants to control
her grave rather that means there's
actually something in that casket or not
i don't know
um i mean i guess it's a good [__]
question um to ask especially seeing
that this [__] has
empty folders of top secret documents
and and and the guy the guy is known to
love to eat
[__]
documents like their their like their
fast food like their drive-through john
like this guy this guy couldn't help but
couldn't help but and i don't know i
don't know if you put i really don't
know i don't know this for sure i don't
know if you put if you order your top
secret documents through the drive-thru
um on a sesame seed bun a regular bun an
onion bun i'm not really sure and i
don't know i don't know what condiments
see i don't like condiments but i don't
know what condiments you actually put on
top of yogurt
wait wait you don't like condiments in
fact no [__] no i don't like ketchup i
don't like mustard nope so you don't put
ketchup on a hamburger and mustard on a
hot dog what the what the [__] am i five
no that's sacrilegious i get the [__]
out of here with that [__]
yeah look how the hell are you gonna
taste how the hell are you gonna taste
the top secret documents if you put
ketchup all over how the hell are you
gonna know what that top secret document
really tastes like how do you spell
ketchup
how do i spell it with a k [__]
yeah because
because
you know some do with the k some do the
other version with the c sorry that's
ketchup
yeah
that's ketchup
no the squeegee thanks for the two bucks
there
um
tony
uh someone was asking a question
it was earlier
but anyway yeah so
oh i was getting back well
somebody was saying that joe biden
i'm sorry you started looking the other
way no i i got [__] going on man there's
all kinds of stuff
i got i got a whole i got a whole uh
command center here you know
all right totally don't do what i do you
gotta have a whole command center so
someone was saying
buy it and learn from the obamas and
jill but i'll tell you something man
i knew
i knew like
and and even when i used to have my
producer my old producer was producing
the show royce and we would talk about
who we wanted
you know our pick to be i always wanted
biden tony
for the very reason you had
you know have said because i knew
that biden would be able
to beat trump in a debate and go to the
gutter
with trump like he'll be able to fight
trump
with the same way trump fights like he's
that guy he's the guy that'll [__]
laugh at him
and do that [__]
just like if you could recall
biden did to paul ryan
at that debate
when biden was vice president i don't
know if that was a debate i thought it
was a spanking yeah i said it was yeah
but tony and i was
how can you not laugh at these [__]
idiots i know and it was so it was like
biden was just schooling paul ryan
you know and that's why i knew he could
beat trump and debates and he did
well i mean not only can he beat trump
and the bates but the the thing that joe
biden does best
and i think everyone should uh should
take a moment to recognize this the
thing that joe biden does best is he's
he's very patient yes right he's not he
he's not like trump where he's got a
like he's got to [__] be
truthing truthing on his [__] fraud
social which that's a whole nother story
this morning um he's [__] posting on
fraud social losing his [__] mind
he's a lunatic because he knows he's
gonna go to [__] prison bill barr
bill barr knows trump's going to prison
yeah i mean that's that's what we're
getting this morning but here's the
thing is that biden is very patient and
biden really understands that hey what
is today
isn't going to be next week isn't going
to be next month and and and i think
cliff said it before i came on he said
look
you know 39 days in politics is [__]
20 years right like we won't even unless
people like me keep yelling and
screaming about [__] that happened two
months ago
they won't [__] understand or
remember the [__] that happened two or
three months ago that's why when i was
saying do you remember
do you remember
when he was calling to declassify
documents for russia when he was
president the reason why is because
he was in the moment because people were
telling him you can't do this you can't
take these documents he's like yes i can
i'll declassify him that's why he was
saying it out loud because he can't help
himself biden doesn't do that
biden's patient he knows what works he
knows government
he knows the functions of government he
knows how it operates
he knows that he has to trust real
economic advisers again with gas prices
right he could have freaked out he could
have done all kinds of [__]
you know big events and big old hoopla
about gas prices and all kinds of
[__] he could have played into this
[__] fear and all this nonsense
and he didn't what he did was he did
what he could do
what he could control
with his office and his power to try to
bring down gas prices now opec they're
going to try to raise gas prices for the
midterms you know this right opec has
announced this week that they're going
to cut off um
actual production because supply is too
high and crude is too low they're not
making enough [__] money it's always
greed with these [__] always
greed and biden knew that by knew it was
always greed with him he knew what was
gonna happen when russia invaded ukraine
he knew that the world was going to say
nope you can't do this russia we're
going to cut you off
from buying oil and gas prices went up
that's just how it works with supply and
demand that's how it works now he also
understood that hey if we put certain
things in place if i encourage the world
to look for different supplies
then we can bring the price of crude
back down which will eventually have an
effect at the pump and he was right he
was right because the president that we
have now understands that we don't just
have a button
that controls gas prices they
he understands that he he only has
certain amount of mechanisms that he can
do to change
what is currently in the market
what do you got oh you jesus christ i
will have some flat jacket
i don't trust anyone that doesn't use
condiments okay well i'll put your mind
at ease i like barbecue sauce there you
go oh there you go i'll dip my [__]
fries in barbecue sauce but ketchup are
you [__] kidding me
the [__] out here what am i what am i
three
you don't like tomatoes huh no i don't
want no slimy ass tomato on my sandwich
i want to taste the top secret documents
john i want to taste that [__] toxic
document then i'm eating then i'm
chowing down hey low the clown thanks
for the five bucks what do you guys
think beto
needs to do
to get it going out in texas
i roll wheels i i think you're talking
about uh greg abbott there is what he's
talking about
to roll greg abbott out of texas i think
beto is doing what he should be doing i
think beto was talking about community i
think beto is going out and he's having
community meetings he's not holding
rallies beto could open up stadiums and
the [__] could sell out stadiums
for tens of thousands of people and he's
not doing it and the reason why is
because that's not what alberto is
winning no beto's not winning going
doing some stupid shtick in front of his
cult members because he doesn't have
[__] cult members
he's got constituents he's got texans
he's got voters and he knows he has to
go to these communities he has to talk
to these voters about their community
and what their concerns are about their
community and he knows he has to make
sure
to give them his ideas that he wants to
move forward to move their community in
texas forward and that's what betto is
doing it is what every democrat's doing
it's what fetterman's doing it's what
tim ryan's doing it is what warnock is
doing
all these other [__] clowns these
maga republican clowns they're trying to
hold big rallies and get and get 20 20's
of people there
and do their little manga fascist stick
and hope that it that
we [__] yell and scream about it and
it gets some coverage well what they
don't know is we're telling all the
people of america just how [__]
fascist they are and it's sticking it's
sticking big time because uh they can't
run away from this just like um they
haven't been able to run away from the
last week since joe biden has pinned
this on their chest but you know i think
i talked to you in private about this
but
aren't you seeing like
like
all the like the jim jordans or like all
these little [__] guy
yeah but all that that's my natural
that's my natural reaction when someone
says no i know but all they're doing now
is like it seems like they're going [__]
it
[__] we might be losing in the midterms
so now we gotta say everything that joe
biden doesn't care about the working
class
like having you noticed this now like
that's all they're doing joe biden
doesn't care about poor people joe biden
is taxing you for the student debt and
you know he's taxing poor people it's
all [__] well i mean if you want to
get into the student debt thing i'll
give you i'll i'll give you a a minute
or two on how do you go out and you
[__] crush these manga republicans on
these shoes
jim jordan and all these [__]
talking about how oh the the student
debt is for the elites it's for the
elites in the world they're trying to
get money to the elites what they're
trying to do is they're trying to
convince
that the trump voters boneheads people
who are delusional will believe anything
trump says anything absolutely anything
like i declassified these with my magic
big mac stained hands like that kind of
[__] right just outright lies
what jim jordan and the other model
republicans are trying to do is convince
their constituents not to apply for the
student debt loan relief and the reason
why is because if they can get enough of
their supporters to not understand that
you have to go apply for it then they
won't get it and if they don't get it
then they'll say oh see the democrats
got it no trump supporters got it yeah
because you didn't apply for it because
you listen to the [__] idiots
stop listening to the [__] idiots and
you will and you'll actually see
what what america is about and what it
can do for you we the people when we
band together and we say hey [__] the
rich people [__] the rich people [__]
the universities [__] the federal
government [__] them we can we can make
sure that students who have had student
debt uh loans in this country who make
under 125 000
can get 10 000 with your relief which by
the way
net 10 000 bucks is barely
barely going to cover the interest that
has been charged over the years for
those loans this isn't like this isn't
like we're losing money that's all
[__] [__]
all these loans this money has already
been paid to the colleges so they're not
losing money
the money that that the treasury has
it's it's our quote unquote our money
right but we've been charging interest
on it with no forbearance of interest
just forbearance of the loan for [__]
decades and decades on in some cases
and these [__] people are are
bitching are you're bitching that that
the federal government is going to wipe
something off their books that they've
already made profit on
this is not this isn't like the
government is losing money
this isn't the government losing money
it's all debt that is repaid with
interest you dumb [__] we're
not raising any taxes no one's paying
any more taxes because this is debt that
the government holds with interest they
make money
they make money on these student loan
debt
they make money we as a people make
money off each other by by convincing
each other that go take student loan
debt from the federal government to go
to college so that you could go make
less than 75 000. and joe biden said you
know that's a bunch of [__] what we
should do is give them 10 000 bucks so
that way we can at least give them some
[__] relief from the way that we've
been them over and [__] them in the
ass without the vaseline for the last
[__] couple decades with this college
[__] as these colleges have raised
prices and we've continued to subsidize
them raising prices and we continue to
do this [__] now i think that the
student debt program doesn't go far
enough but i think it really gets
colleges and universities to understand
that hey maybe just maybe maybe just
maybe we should change how we look at
this and we shouldn't see these as
bodies in our school warm bodies that
give us [__] atm cash maybe the way
we should look at it is we should have a
better outcome and and the reason why i
say that is because they lowered
the maximum payment for your for your
your income your disposable income that
you have from 10 to 5
so really now the colleges have to focus
on how can we get students to have the
highest amount of [__] salary so that
they're because and it's only you only
have to pay for 20 years now 20 years
you're done
so they're going to really leverage that
because they're going to start lowering
the amount that these colleges are going
to get on these federal student loans
hey hey uh hey tony let's have a little
laugh at the expense of patrol
um
this is uh from facebook uh john
john john whatever
aileen biden's too scared to take a
cognitive test because he knows he'd
fail
what's funny about that is and we were
talking about this the other day because
we showed um yesterday we showed on a on
our show because we're live every single
weekday monday through friday noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter twitch so don't forget
to go follow the tony michael's podcast
yes here's the thing
is um while we are live we showed part
of joe biden's speech in milwaukee on
labor and labor day and joe biden wasn't
reading out of a teleprompter the dude
was walking around stage with a
microphone in his head
he was walking around stage and he was
saying he was telling the american
people what the [__] is up that he is
for them and that's what he does at
events
he doesn't just talk out of the
teleprompt they pick out the one little
[__] time that he does something and
they play that over and over and over
again and this dark brandon thing has
really got to him oh it's really [__]
with him you know they did this let's go
brandon as [__] yo biden and and you
know basically the white house has taken
this back i mean the left you could say
but really the white house has taken
this narrative back that you goddamn
right it's brandon he's gonna whip your
manga ass like that's that's kind of the
projection that they're giving
look tony tony i love
okay
john a fellaini
you are a you are an idiot
uh ready uh but biden and his crime
family and a lot of democrats will all
be in jail soon okay worst president
ever and probably most corrupt too
is that trump is that trump over is he
over there on facebook
he hasn't had a facebook account many
months
he's the best president ever
i i mean i don't know how to help these
people i mean you know the the saddest
part is is that
that
if we want to use the example the
student debt
relief is that the student net relief is
actually going to give
working families families that make
under 125 000 and in particular people
who make under 75 000 because that's the
majority of people that are actually
going to benefit from this
um relief if they want it right right if
they go get it now if they believe dumb
[__] like jim jordan and don't apply
for it and then they're gonna whine and
complain that they didn't get it and
elites got it again they're just playing
into the absolute delusion and lies
because it really is it really is going
to be people under 125 000 and really
again the majority of people that hold
debt is going to be under
75 000. i love this catherine defilippo
warning mag got meltdown in progress
the maggots like to melt down i mean
this is their mo
but you know what it's so true tony well
first of all i do want to compliment you
on
that great uh outline of the student
debt and exactly what they're doing and
i hope everybody
repeats what tony just said and everyone
should watch tony's show i do and as you
know i do because i'm in the chat even
though you ignore me
i i i i've had a tough time lately
keeping up with the chats we got yeah
right now i know it's hard to do and
that's why i got fooled today with some
idiot you know because because you're
trying to do everything at once
so you're not paying attention to every
troll thing they're doing but i'll tell
you
the way you outlined it is is great so
what we should do and tony are you on
true social
i i have an account over there so i can
watch what the cheetos mobster does you
should be on there telling these
dumbasses
don't listen to these guys go out and
apply for this loan
because if you don't you're not going to
get it well i mean i mean eventually the
fever is gonna break here um and and
then they're gonna they're gonna
eventually understand because we're
gonna start to see reports about uh well
in particular
when someone challenges in court because
someone's going to challenge this in
court is unconstitutional which
honestly that is probably the the best
debate to have
is
does the president united states have
the power to wipe away student debt like
this i mean that that is a legitimate
question that we have not answered right
that is that's the real debate now
rather it's good for elites or [__]
poor people that's not a debate because
the program is set up for people who
make under 125 000 yes this is not
[__] complicated to understand now
because they won't say that
a lot of these people won't know that
but trust me when i say this
when these boneheads who have a shitload
a shitload if you if if they have a
shitload of debt and they make 125 000
they realize they can wipe away ten
thousand dollars all they have to do is
fill out a form apply for it get the you
know get the proper paperwork and they
can get their ten thousand dollars wiped
off their debt they will and here's why
john
of all student debt is under 10 000
that's and and here's the thing
this is going to wipe out this program
if all those people apply for this
program it'll wipe out
45 of all federal student loan debt
because that's how low it is and the
reason why john
is because unfortunately a third of all
student loan debt does not have a degree
to back it meaning people went to
college like me they took they they went
to college they took out loans and they
dropped out for whatever reason i'm a
two-time college dropout john that's why
i can't say momentos
so i can't say that because i'm a
two-time college dropout right but
that's the thing that's the thing is
that a third of all student federal
student debt
is held under ten thousand dollars by
people who do not have a degree to back
it which means if you can you know use
logic and rational
uh uh rationale
i'm following well that these people
don't actually make a 75 000 they're not
making a college degree amount and
really honestly most professions that
require a degree in this country
actually don't even make 75 000 there is
a lot of high-end jobs quote-unquote
high-end jobs in the midwest
that people have degrees for i'm talking
rns
nurses people who we rely on to get
continuing education teachers
in some cases
they don't make 125 000 john because 125
000 here in the midwest is a hell of a
lot hell of a lot more money here than
it is in new york or la where you're at
and i know that there's probably people
even in
in la that are in new york and other
places that are that our cost of living
is higher in this country probably don't
even make 30 or 40 000 with college
degrees and that is the real thing that
that republicans don't want to say and
the reason why is because then they have
to have a discussion
about [__] a workable [__] income
they don't want to have that discussion
because that's what joe biden is so
smart here that's why democrats have all
if they just use their [__] heads and
they use messaging as opposed to as
opposed to not use messaging because
they've done this for a long time
they've not been very good
if they just use messaging they can
force these conversations because i
think that's the conversation coming
down the pike um when this is challenged
in court
and when there's reports of how many
people act out there have student debt
that haven't applied yet
that's gonna be that when the stories
start to come out that hey people aren't
applying for this damn thing why aren't
people applying for this thing it's
because republicans had told them that
it's for the elites and like oh it
doesn't apply to me because i i don't
make any money yeah that's exactly who
it applies to you and when they realize
that they'll go apply for it they'll get
the [__] student debt relief there's
no one not gonna wipe away their student
debt because of [__] what jim
jordan's dumbass says i mean come on
hey speaking of uh well first of all
fellow the clown thanks for the two
bucks has oprah ever disowned her little
dog oz uh i would hope so at this point
you know
well i i mean a lot of people bring
blame
um blame uh
uh oprah for dr oz but
i don't know if it's all her fault she
definitely gave him a platform but
he's he's a [__] because of it and
with other reasons other than [__]
oprah so
tony just to show you uh here's a guy
who can't pass the cognitive test this
is this is how a real president handles
a heckler
this is this is [__] awesome yeah go
ahead
and it's not i mean it from the bottom
of my heart
as i said last week
we remain in the battle
for the soul of america
by the way
all right god love you
let him go
no no no no no no no no no no no don't
let him go let him he's look everybody's
entitled to be an idiot
no no everybody's there okay
i mean it's the truth john it's the
truth
everyone's entitled to be an idiot
that's how i feel with these trolls that
come in the room
you know what i mean it's okay
let me be a [__] idiot yeah right let
him go it's your [__] i mean if you
want to look like a dumb [__] hey more
power to you
i mean i think that's i think that's
where we're at in this country is is we
let them expose themselves we just stand
back and let them expose themselves and
tony like
i don't expect you but maybe you did
uh uh notice it but i do because i'm a
stutter at it did you notice the w he
had a problem with he was like
it took him
you know he had to it you know it took
him a while to get to the word because
w's were always hard for me
right
well and i i guess i guess i just i
don't really because i don't even know
how to say um momento um i don't even
you're not gonna let this go are you no
[__] you right hey tony
i'm a teacher i'm one of those teachers
who who are on the page yeah yeah yeah
but the point is the point is is that i
don't really
i mean i mean i think i think though uh
how you say something is important um
and i and i'll agree that joe biden
lacks some of that uh you know
that skill that like barack obama had uh
bill clinton had where they could just i
mean
really clap right like clap back in in
the way that they said it and how they
said it um but i mean
in reality though
joe biden understands the politics of
everything and i don't think that he was
trying to be on messaging there i just
think he generally is like no let him go
don't [__] with him he's he's not
hurting nobody all he's doing is saying
stupid [__] yeah he's just saying stupid
[__] that no one here will believe
because he's a [__] idiot they aren't
i mean i have these most these people
showed up because they support american
workers
they support american workers and this
guy obviously does not support american
workers and that's to his detriment
maybe by him yelling and screaming and
seeing that these people in this crowd
don't don't go along with his dumb
[__] maybe he'll understand and maybe
he'll start to grasp why
what he's saying and what he's doing is
stupid i mean you do you're entitled you
really are entitled to be an idiot in
this country i mean that that is what
liberty affords you now the greatest
part about it
about uh these people being stupid is we
get to know who they are that's that's
about we don't have to guess anymore
like whoa
well look at look at this group of
[__] moglodites over here
um i would imagine there's a lot of
stupidity
wrapped around that group i don't know
about you tony but sometimes it's kind
of uh you know
always touches my heart you know like
cindy weber givens i really love you
guys
she means me but i mean you know you're
you're on the screen here with me so
well you're knocking me for saying a
word and that you know
you [__] with me all the time
that's funny sometimes when john calls i
say what the [__] do you want yeah yeah
yeah [__] exactly
exactly so don't even don't even think
about going in and
uh look cher okay now here's another
lunatic right
again
now hold on that's reality okay sherry
trump was accused of rape
by a 13 year old okay there's your
pedophile as far as the racist stuff
goes
noel castler worked on the apprentice
said trump used the n-word so many times
it wasn't funny and when
um
holly robinson pete was supposed to win
he said in the elevator with a bunch of
executives they want me
to let the
n-word win okay sherry that is a racist
and if you really want me to go farther
sherry fred trump
wouldn't allow
wouldn't rent apartments to people of
color
okay sherry
do you know that sherry
you dumb [__]
well i mean she's on he's she's on
facebook i mean you can't really i mean
i'm not trying to knock all the facebook
people but really honestly if you're not
over here on youtube in the chat you're
on i'm just kidding look sherry skaggs
here again she's entitled to be a
[__] idiot she's entitled to believe
really stupid [__] [__] she's
entitled to believe all kinds of lies
and she's entitled to not not and
not pay attention and ignore the truth
because the truth and the fact of the
matter is
that not all um
nazis are republicans but at this point
all manga republicans
are [__] nazis so 100 more more power
to you uh sherry
i i wish you
all the best um
in your
delusional little world that you live in
i i don't you know you know what i got
to tell you tony i i laugh at these
people you know it sometimes i feel sad
for him and sometimes i laugh
it's like there's certain like you know
it's a certain
certain poc face idiot decided to start
saying that my chat like i have a friend
who's going through cancer you know that
i'm somehow pocketing the money
and now and he got so
woke he's been trashing me left and
right
how did i get to you pocky
these these [__] i'm telling you poor
pocky's woke oh
these [__] fascist snowflakes
it really is it really is it really is
um
it really is funny that these uh fascist
snowflakes are are the worst crybabies
in the world and it's no more
apparent when joe biden's like you're
semi-fascist you're like oh my god did
you hear that he called us [__] nazis
well you are nazis he didn't say i say
nazis i say their let's go brandon
america versus nazis they're moglodites
they're trump lodites they're trump
bumpers
they're cheeto dust suckers listen
there's all kinds of names that we could
use for you [__] dumb [__]
but joe biden chose the word
semi-fascist and you freaked out you
bunch of god damn [__] you bunch of
goddamn snowflake [__]
just [__] own up to it quit being
such [__] babies why are you such
[__] [__] i don't understand it i
just don't get it how they're they they
pound their chest act like they're
masking them in they tan their [__]
balls they talk about how
paint your nails and and coloring your
hair is gonna make you you know gay or
something they can't focus on anything
but someone else's [__] genitalia
these people
are [__] weirdos john they're [__]
weirdos they're just
[__] weirdos i know and tony you and
i get it from these loons
but to me it's so just it's so
hysterical
it's like
first of all donald trump called all
democrats [__] fascists
in august
so you know so i mean but they don't
want to talk about well yeah but he
didn't he didn't know the word fish fish
the fish is fish i mean he says fascism
like i say mementos fish fishes
fascism fest democrat fishism that's
what he said i think
i
hey high anxiety thanks for the five
bucks hey john what about the conspiracy
theory about ivana suddenly falling down
some stairs a month before and the eggs
expires that is kind of weird and i
always kind of question that because
i'll just tell you marla maples
immediately after that happened got
special security
i mean that was a news well i mean
here's the thing is you want to talk
about wives and ex-wives
melania trump's team put out a statement
after they they served the search
warrant on mar-a-lago and it was and he
kept talking about her [__] closet
melania trump's like that [__]
didn't come in my bedroom that
motherfucker's not allowed anywhere near
my [__] bedroom let alone my [__]
closet that's that [__] fat slob is
not supposed to be in my wing of
mar-a-lago i mean they have separate
bedrooms separate closets shouldn't even
[__] live there probably half the
time why would you i mean the only time
that she probably lives there when he
ain't there i mean why would you want to
be in mar-a-lago when that
motherfucker's there would you want to
be anywhere near that son of a [__] i
wouldn't i mean i i take that back i
take that back
john i i would love to have the
opportunity to be within spitting
distance of donald trump now i'm not
saying i would i'm just saying so i
could yell you know fascism
fascism or something like that but i
would love
to be within spitting distance of donald
trump i'm just saying
phallo the clown um thanks for five
bucks bite and don't sell cards that do
nothing like that soggy cheeto does
trump card is trump selling cards now
yeah he sells a train well that's one of
his grips
is he sells like a trump gold card
you're a you're a trump gold member or
some [__] you're a member of the cult
right you gotta i mean if you're a cult
you gotta have a you have a cult card
right um i guess i don't know if they
they punch you know the card and you get
a free rally every three rounds you go
to or something because it's the same
[__] at these rallies i don't
know if you notice that but
i'll tell you tony that's why
the mighty touch brothers have a great
name because trump loves the color gold
everything's gold so i love that they're
they're midas and they're [__] with
them all the time
right right
well i i've only got a few more minutes
so can i plug can i plug the minus touch
and ronnie you could plug anything you
want my friend
you don't want me to do that you don't
want me to do that i mean i could plug
all kinds of things but i'll plug i'll
plug my show um of course the audience i
think here mostly knows that we we go
live every single week day monday
through friday noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific on youtube twitter and
twitch and we simulcast for the midas
touch facebook page for two hours every
single weekday we i do not give up i do
not stop talking
um i talk the entire two hours every
single day we go through
yeah we got a good audience growing so
come
come subscribe to the youtube channel
just type in tony michael's podcast or
tony michaels now you'll go to the tony
michaels podcast youtube channel
subscribe there you can follow me on
twitter at the tony michaels or you can
follow the podcast on twitter at
tonymichaelspod
um so if you want to support free
free pro
pro democracy speech
um come come watch us every single
weekday what are you [__] laughing at
leslie
oh [__]
yeah you sons of [__]
[Laughter]
yeah [__] uh trump special master baja
king uh thank you trump retweeted video
of kui griffin that this is that this is
that cowboys gay oh the only good
democrat is a dead one oh he's the one
that made it that made video cowboys for
trump really is that what they said
the only good democrat is a dead one
well i mean this is what these these
people think they oh they're trying to
kill us they're trying
and they're the ones that are
threatening violence they're the ones
that are threatening to kill people hey
tony i don't need to pat myself from the
back but
i was one of the first shows that had
you on isn't that true the one you're
one of the first well you and brad
berkwit
brad burke would have me but i i said i
was one of them well you're one of them
yeah yeah yeah are you trying are you
trying to say that you have something to
do with my success is that what no no no
no i'm not howard stern but i will say
thank you you definitely namely your or
not
no but i will say yeah that uh i i i did
say one of the first times that you were
on if you could recall yeah i said that
i see you guys being like
you know big like the minus touch guys i
see you guys i'm gonna have the biggest
hottest political podcast don't you
remember i said tony you're gonna be a
star i am a star what do you mean gonna
be i am no i said it all the all that
long i was a star then just no one knew
it all right no one knew it i'm the i'm
the biggest thing since sliced bread
[__] biggest thing since uh
since a sleeve of mementos
and you're very
and you're very modest
yeah i'm very modest
modest in my ways because i hate
fascistism
no [__] and you know hold on we got
another super chat here toni anthony
let's see if this is a real one anthony
c blood thanks for the 20 bucks love
john when you were on stern everyone
including you said lots of offensive
things here we go and i made some of
this great of all time
as you of age you think you have turned
into the guy who had tried to ban stern
first of all it was a different time it
was different time different era things
have changed different era
and uh what was it era era
era no really
now you put it in that was the frauding
slip i was thinking of uh just allison
[__] in the game yesterday you know
uh making an error but um yeah that was
a very long time ago very long time and
things were different in those days but
in 2022 i think we all know
what words are offensive and what words
aren't thank you anyway
tony so what else do you want to plug my
friend oh well just just go follow my
show and follow me on twitter and hey if
you want you can go to
thetonymichaels.com
and you can find all the all the links
there for all the social media and the
podcast and downloads and if you do it
on spotify or apple if you want to
listen to my beautiful voice instead of
watching my beautiful face which i don't
know why you'd want to not see my
beautiful face um but you know i i i can
see how someone would just want to
listen to my
my very beautiful voice i could see that
i just can't believe that you don't like
condiments i mean you know i guess
you're not afraid of getting your way
pregnant
yeah well i mean condiments condiments
get in the way man
tony i love it come on you and gabe did
had a field day with me on my dc trip i
could laugh at one word that you say i'm
still trying to figure out if you got a
craigslist account i still go try to see
if you're putting [__] craigslist out
there craigslist ads out there tony i
love you i'm i'm a little upset gabe
wasn't here though i love gabe too i'll
i'll let him know like i said they
arrested him for having uh top secret
document empty folders i mean anyone
they arrested him on the spot because
that's what they would do is arrest
someone on the spot if they had um empty
top secret uh folders just harbored at
their home in the basement of their
homes so we hope to get gabe out of uh
and a jail soon i don't want to build
your echo but um roberta denies says uh
stuttering john this has been an awesome
panel sir
i am an awesome panel what are you
talking about i don't want to build up
your ego any more than it is
full of mementos
ah [__] you john
uh here's here's what i'll say one last
thing before i go is uh that
i i think i think that we need to
continue to speak out i think your
audience can should continue to speak
out i think they should
follow pro-democracy speech everywhere
um if they get the whiff of the media
not being pro-democracy uh just get them
[__] off and come over somewhere where
they can
actually
see what pro-democracy is about because
i think that is the most important thing
for us to engage in our democracy i
think that's how we save it from this
physicism as trump would say i think i
think we got to make sure that we head
this off of the past that we win uh not
just the senate but the house of
representatives and well beyond that we
got to win some of these governor races
we have to win in these state
legislators we have to win these
secretary of state races because they're
really going to try because
the the threat is not violence in the
street folks
it's not going to be violence in the
streets it's going to be them being
inside of our government these [__]
insurrectionists these maga republicans
who are fascist who want to take our
democracy down the way that they're
going to try to do it is inside our
governments and that is up to you you
still have the right to vote you still
have the ability to vote
and you better use it before they lose
it because they're gonna they're gonna
take it away from you
and just like they took away bodily
autonomy from women they're coming for
your vote they're coming for your rights
they're coming for your way of life
they're coming for your religion they're
coming for everything so
i don't know what this means tony
failover clown
[__] fight ass to the bail account like
the christian battle oh no no no no for
a game for gabe bale he's got to make
bail
oh that's right yeah
well
well he spelled bell wrong so like
that's like a bale of hay not like uh
bail you out of jail yeah no no i think
it's for i think it's for gabe is for
gabe he's not actually arrested i was
kidding he was in a meeting well
gabe he better get his ass on here i
will i'll tell hispanics got to stick
together well if you would spell his
name right you know you spelled his name
wrong on the thing you called him lopez
his name is sanchez what that's the
second time i did that i know i know i
know well i you you are stuttering john
melinda so i mean it happens i say
momento you say lopez instead of sanchez
yeah i don't know that's the second time
i did that i don't know i don't know
that maybe that's correct maybe maybe
john that's no he he had a meeting he
had a media name he's going to so
yeah change it change it there so all
the trolls see that you changed it
and i'll go i'll go delete some more
videos off my youtube um before i come
on the next show so uh
we'll see you soon buddy you know you
haven't made it unless you have trolls
dude i've i've got plenty of them
because of you so
i'll talk to you soon john we'll talk to
you soon buddy
all right great uh tony michaels on the
show that was a lot of fun and yes gabe
sanchez i'm sorry i
second time for some reason it's stuck
in my head lopez
i don't know why but it's sanchez like
gary sanchez who hit a home run off of
this yesterday as a payback
yeah little clown thanks for all your
donations they're two bucks
yeah this pocky
guy is so upset
oh god he was gonna
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
pled guilty for domestic violence
well that's not funny actually but it's
funny that he's so upset with me
anyway um everybody um
thank you so much
for all the super chats today i want to
thank my moderators andrea brauer and
benny loco
i also want to thank um my guest today
cliff schechter and tony michaels uh and
gabe lopez i also want to um
uh
let's see there was some oh i want to
thank my sponsor ben online.ag
uh
yeah yeah
yeah take this pocky and kevin from
wwp thank you for the two bucks yeah
yeah he's a guy you know that i mean i
mean he got fired apparently because he
he had a racist twitter tirade and he
got canned that's what the news story
said
um
but i mean and
you know and then this guy
is so upset because i said that he he's
a liar because he's saying that i'm
pocketing charity money he got so upset
that he decides to trash
my transgender child
i mean this is this is this is the level
this is the level
of despicable but
this is how low this person is
okay it's i mean
you you should only feel sad
this is the level of how
of how low you can be
but i've you know i've already reached
out to rain
glad
and bullies out
because this
and twitter support because this kind of
[__] should not be allowed
you know homophobia transphobia now man
not not in
this day and age just because you got a
little butt hurt
because uh i called you out for calling
me a you know
for stealing a good friend's
cash that i collect
for her spouse who's going through
expensive chemo and you had the audacity
to lie about me and call me out and then
because i i call you out for your lies
you get all butthurt
[Laughter]
oh
uh
ah
throw the drill thanks for the five
bucks pocket should be the last person
to criticize trans people yeah i know
he's he he's got enough problems of his
own you know i mean allegedly i mean he
was arrested right for biting his
young way young he could be
he's old enough to be her father biting
her hand and then i don't know
i know he got arrested i you know i
already pleaded guilty you know i don't
know
and that's what i read i don't know you
know if it's a wedge it's a legend but i
mean i mean that's what i read i don't
know who would be biting some
young girl's hand this sounds a little
sick to me
i mean but you know i mean that's him i
mean i you know i've never been fired
from a job for any of the
horrible offenses he has
uh uh committed but anyway uh i'll see
you guys oh
i'm gonna be back here tomorrow okay
because i'm filling in
for a friend of mine
who is going on vacation on thursday so
he's he's the friend that told me that i
i should become a substitute teacher
because he says how badly that we need
so he asked me to fill in for him
and uh you know do his english um um
eighth grade english so
i'm gonna fill in for him on thursday
and friday so instead i'll do my show
tomorrow at noon
pst so just let everybody know i'm in
the process of booking nicki freed
she was supposed to um
be i i screwed up she was supposed to be
on thursday
and and i just realized that i told my
buddy that i i'd fill in for him
so i so on thursday and friday so i'm
not gonna do a thursday show oh
on another note of course you know all
these dumbass trolls have their own
have their own reasonings for why i
didn't do a show on sunday but of course
it's all just horseshit
as
most everything that they say about me
including pocky's you know false
allegations
uh you know and he got so hurt i'm gonna
beat up stutter and john knowing
benjamin
and opie
[Laughter]
oh and benjamin and opie are hurting me
oh and stuttering john is a liar
i'm so sad
[Laughter]
oh boy
anyway um
i i
couldn't do the show i had a showing on
my house
at that time
so i had to clean and then get out of
and then get out of my place so i
couldn't stream that's the real
that's the real reason so just to get
the schedule
it's going to be tomorrow wednesday and
then saturday both at noon then saturday
there's going to be another beer on the
balcony with i think rich talarico or
elon gold and then on sunday will be my
special
uh stuttering john's uh sunday stern
special whatever it's called all right
everybody i'll see you tomorrow at noon
pst it's stuttering john saying
[Music]